Hilary Clinton meanwhile thousands of
miles away in India as a result she
figures it safe to say what she really
thinks about you watch his whole
campaign make America great again was
looking backwards you know you didn't
like black people getting rights you
don't like women you know getting jobs
you don't want it you know see that
Indian Americans succeeding more than
you are whatever your problem is I'm
gonna solve it we don't do well with
married white women and part of that is
a an identification with the Republican
Party and a a sort of ongoing pressure
to vote the way that your husband your
boss your son whoever believes you
should notice who Hillary Clinton did
not blame for her loss herself or her
ideas or anything she's ever said or
done but it is a mistake though to make
this about Hillary Clinton she's a
figure of the past but her ideas are
very much a feature of the present the
clip you just heard precisely sums up
the view of the left in America right
now a bigoted middle class is holding
back progress they believe that so the
Democratic Party voters in the middle of
the country don't have legitimate views
or aspirations they have only ugly gut
reactions they're racists and dumb
people white women as Hillary Clinton
said they can't think for themselves
they're puppets of their husbands and
sons worst of all they're attached to
those stubborn little cells of
Independence called families and nothing
stands in the way of power like families
so they must be smashed
that's the message Hillary maybe washed
up but she understands perfectly well
what the goals are Julie Alvin is life
style director at the Meredith
Corporation she joins us tonight Julie
thanks coming up thanks for having me so
I don't want to beat up on Hillary
Clinton I mean you bring me on no I'm
actually sincere I feel what she lost I
always feel sorry for the loser
I think she's become less popular among
Democrats she's humiliating herself so I
don't want to pound on her but I do want
to talk about the ideas I'm really
struck cuz I think she's the perfect
sort of embodiment of an attitude that
pervades that
mechanic party right now which is we
lost and it's your fault
you're bigots you're standing in the way
of progress America and I think that's a
what do you think of that attitude it's
everywhere I don't think it's a fair
attitude I you know I think one thing
one valid point that a lot of people
make when talking about a lot of the
statements that Hillary Clinton makes is
that she doesn't necessarily talk about
the tactical errors that her team made
as far as campaigning as far as
appealing to the middle of the country
so you know while I certainly am
personally against the administration
that's currently in office and a lot of
the things that I believe that they
stand for right I think that the
Democrats also need to account for the
errors that they made during the 2016
election I don't know though because I
hear that a lot I know all the people
who worked you know the the top people
on the Hillary campaign they're really
smart they're all smarter than I am they
had a billion dollars there wasn't
really a lot of tactical thinking that
they didn't you know that they weren't
aware of like they did the tactics right
I don't know that they did I mean could
the problem have been that they didn't
understand that the middle class of the
country was dying in absolute terms and
felt hated and dismissed by them that
maybe was the problem don't you think
well I think when I talk about a
tactical issue I think that not
appealing to that middle part of the
country not understanding how to deliver
the economic messaging that would really
resonate with those people yeah I think
that that was a tactical error yes I
would say it's a thematic error it's
it's kind of a deep error what do you
think of Hillary's the line and again
I'm not beating up on her but I think
this kind of gets to one of the core
contradictions in modern feminism you
know that white women as she said with
disdain voted for Trump because they
were pressured by their husbands and
sons
she thinks that women are so weak minded
that they're bossed around by their sons
and the voting booth doesn't that tell
you a lot it's not revealing well as
much as I hate that soundbite from her
and I wish that you know it it makes it
sound as though women are incapable of
making their own decisions when it comes
to to the voting booth but as much as I
wish this weren't true there actually is
data
that up there was a study by Oregon
State University a couple of years ago
that said that women and specifically
white women are unduly pressured by
their partners when it comes to making
political decisions and generally that
women happened to basically women when
they are unmarried they tend to vote
with the good of their gender in mind
whereas once they become married they
are more likely to vote in their
husbands best economic interests and
this is largely because women hold less
money and earn less money and hold less
power in this country and there actually
is evidence to back up the fact that
women when married and specifically
white women tend to vote with their
husbands economic and economic interest
in mind and that is perceived to be for
white women at least I wonder so if you
have a group of people married white
people and you spend like a huge amount
of time attacking them on the basis of
their race and their marital status as
the Democratic Party in that surrogates
do constantly they attack married people
well sure well of course because that's
not their constituency I mean their
policies are aimed at the unmarried
because married people don't vote for
them explicitly vastly untrue last week
Chuck Schumer said he wasn't going to
support a federal judicial nominee
because he was white and I just wonder
like is that it what do you think that
net effective that is is that good for
the country for politicians to say that
kind of thing out loud well I think that
your mischaracterizing the fact that
Republicans are excuse me that Democrats
are not trying to appeal to married
people that's a huge swath of the
population I think that they're trying
to appeal to a specific ideology and
that was an ideology that is adopted by
both married and unmarried people I like
married women and I think I think I have
a higher opinion of women than you do
and I'm not a feminist I mean I think
they kind of vote the way they want to
vote that's the ones I know do I mean I
I think that that is by and large sure
and I think that some of the things that
Hillary Clinton said oversimplified it
in that particular instance but there is
a little bit of data unfortunately and I
wish it were not the case to back up
what she said there your brave woman to
say that on TV Julie thank you